when he woke up he was in total darkness
what is here mark a special agent for
the United States Secret Service they
know captain in the trunk of a car
I need help my phone is about to die
please reach the Secret Service tell
them what's happening sir I need you to
try and stay calm when the clock started
ticking the game began that's what we
want to know when we pull over and we
make a deal information Jeremy is it you
there's a window they made it personal
all I know is this has something to do
is from let you know Buster it's an
underground bunker with the president
vice president were taken at the sever
an attack on Washington confers change
randomly without notice only a handful
of people ever know which one it is on
any given day that's why they call it
romantic
what are you talking about car bombs
your light inside one you want
information on business bunker given the
location for letter I start executing
these people one by one tell me know
[Music]
it's not there please
[Laughter]